Skyscrapers,
missiles,
cigars,
war memorials,
post boxes.
All examples
of the thrusting, virile,
long-lasting stamina
of male achievement.
And all, uncannily, celebrating
a specific part of the male body.
Phallocentrism is the idea
that the phallus, or the penis,
is central to the human experience.
Not just the phallus
on its own, of course,
but, also, that luckiest of people
in the world - an owner of a phallus.
A proper person, a man.
"Why?" asked Sigmund Freud.
Because, obviously,
it's the best part.
Men know it, and women
who disagree are just envious.
They probably secretly
wish they had one too.
Why settle for a fig, he argued,
when you can have a banana,
or a cucumber,
or a stick of salami.
They actual word "phallocentrism,"
was coined by Welsh psychoanalyst,
Alfred Ernest Jones.
He was a close friend
and biographer of Freud,
but disagreed with Freud's theory.
If anything, he argued,
his belief that women
were so envious of men's bits
revealed far more about Freud
than a secret female plot.
"Relax," he told his friend,
"no woman is going to sneak up
and steal your little Sigmund."
So, he created
the phrase phallocentrism,
to criticise his Austrian friend's
penis-based paranoia.
The phrase was later picked
up by feminists
to articulate the experience
of living in a patriarchal society
and its obsession with
the male view, gaze and audience.
The male experience
in our culture is the default,
the home screen, the universal,
the factory setting, they argued.
In reaction to this, female artists
began to create their own work
that articulated
the female experience,
and created works that celebrate
the curves of the female
reproductive parts.
They also reclaimed
earlier ancient works of art
that celebrated female power.
All to remind the Freudians
of this world,
women are perfectly happy
living penis-free lives.
Sometimes a cigar, is just a cigar.